uh this is from the mirror it says nikki
and graham scott's gender reveal party
started out like any other the couple
from ontario canada celebrated the
momentous occasion as they revealed the
gender of their baby to wider family but
their child wasn't a tiny tot yet to be
born the party was for their
eight-year-old daughter after quote
unquote she told them she no longer
wanted to live as a boy
ella scott eight first told her parents
that she didn't feel like a boy
inside when she was six
and then they decided to throw this big
public gender reveal party
gender reveal announcing their uh
their child's quote-unquote new gender
to the world and
this is what parents do
as we always talk about it as a it's yes
it's virtue signaling okay yes they're
using their kids as fashion accessories
and pawns to signal their own virtue to
the world
but also there's a there's an actual
strategy behind it and what they're what
they're looking to do is
is a lock
as much as they claim
that they want their child to be able to
explore freely and make all free
decisions now what they're doing is
they're locking their child down in that
false identity
by making it into a public spectacle
i mean what
how else is the child supposed to
interpret that you've thrown a party
invited all family and friends you've
announced it on the you've gone to the
media and told everybody about it
now you've put all this pressure on your
child on purpose saying
this is who you are now
if you change your mind that's gonna be
very embarrassing and disappointing for
lots of people so you can't change your
mind
you're stuck with this
that's the strategy behind it now
i i checked on youtube to see if this
interview was available there so i could
play it rather than read it and i didn't
find it but i did find something else um
that very much related to this
this is an apparently prominent youtube
youtuber youtube family it's got 1.7
million subscribers i know i'm gonna
mispronounce the name i don't know how
i'm supposed to pronounce this um
sakon jolies i don't know
s-a-c-c-o-n-e-j-o-l-y-s that's that's
the channel and it's this family uh
apparently
mother and father and they've kind of
like raised their kids on youtube and
they've been exploiting their kids for
for youtube fame for a long time well
just a couple of weeks ago the reason
that this popped up when i was looking
for this other interview is that they
unveiled their own trans eight-year-old
and i wanted to show you
uh a little bit of this video watch this
hey guys welcome to our video
today i thought we would do something
fun don't mind the fact that edie now
looks fabulous okay because in between
making this video we actually shot tick
tock where we straighten the hair this
is my first time ever straightening hair
by the way can i can i can we get some
can we get some like applauses here
i did a pretty good job right
you say yes father that is the best hair
straightening i've ever seen she's also
wearing lashes
oh my goodness oh my goodness anyway we
thought we would make a video because so
many people have been asking us and to
talk about all the other names that edie
um did not use
uh when when she was changing her name
to eat delicious she is officially
delicious but shortened
it's just eating but we decided we'd
make a video yeah
and
i thought it'd be better if edie made
the video so in her own words she's
going to tell you guys bring you on a
journey
a journey
okay
so their son uh now quote unquote
identifies as a girl with the name
delicious and as you can see there in
the video this uh
father and i use that term
only in the biological dictionary
definition sense of the term and no
others
um
this father is uh
holding his son up in front of a camera
you know wearing makeup and false
eyelashes
hair hair grown out straighten the hair
so this father
has dolled up his own son as a girl and
is now
just literally holding him up in front
of the camera saying look at this look
what i got
here's the point to make about this i've
made many points about it in the past
but this is um
this is abuse obviously yes but this is
sexual abuse of a child and i really
think we need to start
putting it that way and being specific
in that way
because when you just say well this is
abusive towards a child that should be
enough for people right that should
carry enough power
um because any kind of abuse is horrific
when inflicted on a child
but but i think it needs it needs more
specificity we need to be more specific
in the charge
that we are
making
so this is this is in fact a form of
sexual abuse of a child
and the parents that do this to their
kids
that cross-dress their kids
and give them these false sexual
identities
especially dress up their sons and
makeup and false eyelashes that would be
inappropriate for a girl of that age
i mean how weird would it be if that was
an actual girl and the father was
holding her up in front of camera look i
gave her look i did her hair and i gave
her false eyelashes i mean how weird
would that be weird as an understatement
so this is the sexual abuse of a child
the people that do this are sexual
abusers of their own kids that's what we
need to say because it's true
if you want to join my exclusive fan
base or a cult as really that's what it
is or joy we're forming a cult then all
you gotta do is click the subscribe
button and ring the bell below uh this
video to stay up to date with all my
content and if you want even more you
can watch or listen to my show at
thedailywire.com spotify or apple
podcast looking forward to welcoming you
to the sweet baby gang